right-hander from newark chris flexon
who's back in the big leagues this year
after pitching
last year in south korea last 20 ball
games lowry is banning
356 with six home runs and 15 runs
banning in
and for the year he's hitting 4-10 with
runners in scoring position
flexon trying to get out of a an early
jam the 2-2 pitch
swaying in a drive into right center
field over mitch haniger henniger is
there to make the catch and that will
retire the
side as chris flexon works around a lead
off double by mark cannon no runs one
hit
lefty shamania six up and six down a
three two eighty right he has not
won a game since the 14th of june jp
crawford leads out for the mariners
bottom of the first
hands over the head and the 2-2 pitch to
jp crawford swung out of this though is
a fast ball by him 96.
that'll bring up hanager here's the 02
to hannigan now and he swings and misses
on a high
fastball back-to-back case that'll bring
up kyle
seeger checking the runner the one or
the one-two pitch on the outside going
to ring him up and mania
strikes out three in the bottom of the
first he keeps the mariners off the
board and after one
yes the is and the mariner is going to
score here's third baseman matt chapman
here's the 3-2 pitch and it strikes ray
called
as chris flexing gets his first strike
out of the night he fans matt
chapman chapman strikes out for the
122nd time this year we go to the bottom
of the second
when luis hits the ball it goes out of
the ballpark
two of his last three hits have been
home runs here's the one two two luis
terrence swung on and miss another
fastball throws it by him
four outs for mania all with the k
and that'll bring up dylan moore is
batting 188.
now the o2 pitch and that's bring him up
and up in the zone but that's holbrook
zone is up there apparently tonight
and that's the fifth strikeout for mania
long hitting 189 four home runs two
balls and two strikes
off the first base side of the hill
mania over the top and the pitch
fastball right to the outside corner and
94.
and long has gone a look in a half a
dozen k's
the first time through the lineup for
mania as a ty
france comes to the plate 1-2 pitch
fastball check swing he went around and
that's it for france
and the mariners in the third seven
strikeouts through three innings
for sean manaya they leave a man out of
the fourth no score
seeger struck out looking his first time
up ichiro is still around the ballpark
both mel sees him every day he throws
batting practice he's
he could spit on the uniform he works
out before the games
took a picture with shohei ohtani during
their last
series in seattle those two teams played
each other into and out of the all-star
break
who's making up these schedules sliders
swinging a miss wasn't a strike and
seeger chased it upstairs and
he is strikeout victim number eight of
mania
chris melvin is really close with ichiro
so
you know for bowl mel he enjoys seeing
him when the ears go up there
kellnick is 11 for
103 at bats 11 hits in 103 in bats two
doubles
and a couple of home runs all the
conversations about kelnick spring they
really want him to make the club out of
spring training those
on the outside did fans and supporters
of the mariners
they didn't start him in the big leagues
they said he wasn't ready
came to the big leagues in early may and
shows that he's
far from a finished project a product as
he swings and misses on a breaking ball
away
nine strikeouts through four readings
sean shamania has
been dominant tonight on the fifth
inning a's and mariners no score
so the a's have first and third two outs
and now it's up to lauriano to get a big
hit chris flexon comes to the stretch
and the 1-1 on the way as the breaking
ball hit off of flexson
rolls down the third base line everybody
is safe and the a's take a one-nothing
lead
right off the pitcher a ball that was a
shot up the middle elvis scores from
third
canada goes to second an infield hit for
laureano
and one nothing is in the fifth two outs
and here is first baseman matt
olsen the look in by flexon
and the right-hander's 3-1 pitch on the
way to olson swinging a fly ball into
left center field going back
shedlong going back near the warning
track that pedals some more
and he's there to make the catch and
that'll end the inning the a's get one
run on three hits and they leave a
couple halfway point we head to the
bottom of the fifth
one away here in the bottom of the fifth
or shed long
struck out looking in the third here's
the one two now and
swan gotta miss a fastball by him ten
strikeouts for mania
over four and two thirds and that'll
bring up murphy
now flexon is at the belt right-handed
pitcher right-hand hitter the 1-0
is swung on in drilled on the left field
line for a base hit
that'll score moreland murphy's around
first he's going to second with a double
and the ace take a two nothing lead
sean murphy doubles down the left field
line
and two nothing a's in the sixth is
moreland scored from
second the ace have them loaded for
dangerous hitting marcanna who's been on
base
three times already chigwa another
payoff pitch
swing at a miss he goes right after him
and challenges him with
97 mile an hour gas and canada can't
catch up to it he takes it foul back to
murphy's glove
canager strikeout ground ball to short
hanniger's name
out there in the trade rumors doesn't
mean the mariners are going to trade him
he's a really good player here's the
one-two pitch to hannigar swung out of
miss on a fastball away
that's 11 for mania tonight
what a performance that's 11 strikeouts
he's given up one hit
so the 11 strikeouts ties a career high
murphy drove in the latest run in this
game it was an rbi
double in the sixth this will now be the
11th pitch to murphy two outs and two on
the 3-2
strike three called it is over
second rider finishes the marathon that
is the seventh inning
murphy has drawn one of the
three walks tonight issued by mania the
next pitch
swing destroyed absolutely
obliterated out to left field by the
stairwell take cover tom
murphy puts the mariners on the board
his eighth of the season cuts the a's
lead in half
it's two to one in the bottom of the
seventh generic has walked and struck
out
the o2 swing and a miss good tight
slider down and away
that is 12 strikeouts and a new career
high for mania
an even dozen for the big lefty from
wanata indiana
and now j.p crawford is due he's back
with a 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss a baker's dozen 13 for
mania
as he retires crawford on the k 13
strikeouts through seven innings for
mania
and the lead stays intact murphy hits
one out
brings the mariners closer on to the
eighth inning it's oakland two
and seattle one brings up loriano
and the one-one on the way swung on and
flipped into left that'll be a base hit
chapman has scored brown to third
they're going to hold him there
and the a's take a three to one lead
laureato just kind of fights it off and
dunks it
into left field over the head of the
shortstop crawford
the bases remain loaded everybody moved
up 90 feet
and the a's lead 3-1 in the eighth so
here's
olson and just one out base is loaded
three to one the pitch to matt is swung
on and drilled the right-hander
going back he's there he makes the catch
that'll score the run brown takes the
score on the sac fly
and going from second to third is canna
larianna holds it first
olson delivers the sac fly to right and
it's four to one a's
and now the batter will be second
baseman jed lowry
here's the stretch and again the two two
pitch swung on and a fly ball into
shallow right field
hannigan racing in moore going out it is
going to be
more makes the catch he runs into
henniger
haniger falls on his back but dylan
moore
is able to make the catch and that will
finally
retire the side even after the collision
dylan is able to hang on to it to end
the inning but the a's get a couple we
go to the bottom of the eighth hour
score now
it's the a's four and the mariners won
two on and two outs for the athletics
here in the top of the ninth they lead
it four to one and the batter will be
shortstop elvis andrews
and the 2-2 to andrew swing and a foul
tip into the glove of the catcher tom
murphy for strike three and that's gonna
retire the side
by the way this is jake bauer's pinch
hitting
and the 1-0 to bowers is a swing and a
shot one-up speared by kemp full spin
throws to first for the out
and the a's have won it good play by
tony kemp
if he doesn't make that play the
mariners have the shot with a tied run
coming up